esta vez nos dicen que la sucesión
aritmética a subíndice está definida por
la siguiente fórmula a subíndice y es
igual a 4 más 3 que multiplican a y
menos 1 y nos preguntan cuál es el valor
de la sub índice 20 es decir del
vigésimo término de la sucesión y bueno
te invito a que pausa es el vídeo ya
venir webs por tu cuenta cuál es este
vigésimo término
bien vamos a trabajarlo juntos y bueno
simplemente podemos ver esto de la
siguiente manera lo que estamos buscando
es el término am subíndice 20 es decir
que vamos a reemplazar la y por el
número 20 el vigésimo término y si
usamos la definición de esta sucesión
aritmética entonces cada vez que yo vea
en esta definición que tengo aquí la
letra y la voy a sustituir por 20 porque
estamos buscando este vigésimo término
entonces esto me va a quedar igual a
quien me va a quedar igual a 44
tres que multiplican a menos uno pero
recuerda y va a tomar el valor de 20
porque estamos buscando a su fin dice 20
por lo tanto en lugar de y voy a poner
20 menos uno quiero ser muy claro con
esto realmente lo que estoy haciendo es
cambiándole el valor a y ahora le estoy
poniendo el valor de 20 y por lo tanto
aquí tengo a este subíndice que toma el
valor de 20 y entonces cuando me
encuentro con una y en esta definición
también pongo este número 20 que tengo
aquí y ahora si podemos hacer esto y ver
cuánto va a hacer nuestro resultado
porque me va a quedar esto es igual a 44
más 3 que multiplican a 20 menos 1 lo
cual es 19 de lujo y cuántos esto
bueno pues 4
y 3 por 19 es lo mismo que 50 57 3 por
10 es 30 27 esto de aquí es 57
entonces me va a quedar 4 57 lo cual es
exactamente igual a 61 de lujo ya
tenemos el vigésimo término de esta
sucesión este va a tomar el valor de 61
bien hagamos un ejercicio más así que
bajemos la pantalla para trabajar el
siguiente problema que es este de aquí
dice la sucesión aritmética a subíndice
y está definida por la siguiente fórmula
y aquí nos dan el primer término a 1 es
igual a menos 7 y nos dan una definición
para todos los demás términos nos dicen
que el término a subíndice jim es igual
al término previo menos 2 observa me
dicen a subíndice y es igual
el subíndice y menos 1 ya esto le
quitamos 2 esto es lo que se conoce como
la definición recursiva de nuestra
sucesión aritmética y nos piden el valor
de subíndice 5 así que vamos a
trabajarlo ham subíndice 5 bueno observa
no es el primer término por lo tanto
vamos a utilizar la definición de todos
los demás términos y me dice que azul 26
5 va a ser igual al término anterior es
decir a subíndice 4 a subíndice 45 menos
uno es 4 ya esto le tenemos que quitar 2
ahora observa que todavía no sabemos el
valor de subíndice 4 aún no sabemos
quién es por lo tanto vamos a
averiguarlo déjame cambiar de color y
vamos a ver quién es a subíndice 4 a
subíndice 4 va a ser igual y bueno
utilicemos esta definición va a ser
igual aa subíndice 4 menos uno lo cual
es
dice 3 ya esto le tenemos que quitar 2 y
ahora observa tampoco sabemos quién es a
subíndice tres así que vamos a
averiguarlo a subíndice tres va a ser
igual a quien a a subirse 3 - 1 lo cual
es a subíndice 2 ya esto hay que
quitarle 2 ya esto hay que quitarle 2 ok
tampoco sabemos a subíndice 2 pero
también podemos averiguarlo a su vice 2
va a ser igual a quien a sus 26 2 - 1 lo
cual es a su fin dice 1 ya esto le
quitamos 2 y de lujo ya sabemos cuánto
vale a subíndice 1 por suerte sabemos
que a subíndice 1 vale menos 7 entonces
vamos a utilizarlo este de aquí ya
sabemos que vale menos 7 entonces deja
meter chardo y poner aquí menos 7 y
entonces al subíndice 2 va a ser igual a
menos 7 menos 2 lo cual es menos 9
muy bien si ya sabemos a su 2002
entonces podemos sustituir lo aquí a
subíndice 2 vale menos 9 y entonces a
subíndice 3 me va a quedar menos 9 menos
2 lo cual es menos 11 muy bien una vez
que ya tenemos a subíndice 3 lo podemos
meter por acá a subíndice 3
es lo mismo que menos 11 y entonces ya
puedo obtener el valor de a subíndice 4
a subíndice 4
es lo mismo que menos 11 menos 2 lo cual
es menos 3 muy bien y por último vamos a
utilizar esta información para meterle
aquí voy a reemplazar a a su 15 4 x
menos 13 me va a quedar que a subíndice
5 que es justo el quinto término el
término que queríamos éste va a ser
igual a menos 13 menos 2 lo cual es
menos 15 y está ya tengo cuánto vale el
segundo término el tercer término el
cuarto término y el término que
buscábamos el término quinto por lo
tanto el quinto término es menos 15 y
hemos